[Applaus]
so liebe Zuschauer und
ähm als wä die Stimmung im Land nicht
schon mies genug schwächelt jetzt auch
noch unsere Gastronomie wegen
Fachkräftemangel und Inflation der
deutsche Hotel und Gaststättenverband
DEHOGA warnt diese Woche die Kosten
würden die Gewinne auffressen ja immer
mehr Kneipen und Restaurants machen
schon an mehreren Tagen der Woche dicht
es ist so und nur mal zur Erinnerung zur
Erinnerung 36 000 Betriebe sind während
der Pandemie quasi an oder mit Corona
gestorben ne umso bitterer dass der
damals auf 7% gesenkte
Mehrwertsteuersatz für Speisen im Januar
wieder auf 19 hochgehen soll wissen Sie
was dann ein Schnitzel kostet ernsthaft
was kostet so ein Schnitzel fragen wir
mal ein Mann aus dem Volke wenn dann ein
Schnitzel 35 40 € kostet jetzt noch mal
teurer wird dann können sich das viele
einfach nicht mehr leisten ja klar dazu
bestellst du dir noch ein kleines Bier
für weiß ich nicht 20
30€ dann guckst du aber
blöd okay wenn Jens Spann regelmäßig
Schnitzel für 40 € ist ahnt man warum
man no nicht seine Villa verkaufen
musste ja die
mehrwertsteuerdiskussion großes Thema in
den Wahlkämpfen und die Nöte vieler
Restaurants erkennt man ja oft schon am
Namen ne sei es beim japanischen
nudelsuppenladen schlechte
Rahmenbedingungen im Restaurante
insolventini und natürlich beim Chinesen
Schop zuui oh
Gott das tut wirklich weh so Frage Frage
zieht die Ampel das jetzt durch mit der
Rückkehr der 19% im Januar und hatte da
im Wahlkampf
2021 nicht mal einer was versprochen was
ihm heute leid tun würde wenn er sich
noch an irgendwas erinnern könnte ich
habe dieser verlängerungsentscheidung
zugestimmt und der Einführung in dem
sicheren Bewusstsein das schaffen wir
nie wieder ab also das ist jetzt etwas
was für die Gastronomie auch gelten soll
und da können sie sich drauf verlassen
ja mein Gott was man so erzählt im
Wahlkampf heute sagt Olaf Scholz zum
Thema Mehrwertsteuer Achtung echtes
Scholz Zitat mal
gucken ja ja wirklich wahr gut damit
kann die Branche ja prima planen mal
gucken und übrigens die Erhöhung träfe
ja nicht nur Restaurants sondern auch
Schulkantinen Kitas und Altenheime
andererseits Mathe ist gnadenlos bei 7%
fehlen 3,3 Milliarden im Staatshaushalt
da müsste man schon sagen wo die sonst
herkommen sollen es sei denn man heißt
Markus Söder und setzt noch einen drauf
es kommt nicht nur darauf an die 7% zu
erhalten sondern sie auszudehnen
generell auf Nahrungsmittel und
natürlich endlich auch auf Getränke
meine Damen und Herren endlich Maline
gescheide und ordentliche Lösung an der
Stelle
sauf ja genial oder in dem Bierzelt
voller besoffener fordern dass das Bier
billiger wird ne dass das funktioniert
wer hätte das gedacht ja war übrigens
bei einer Veranstaltung des
lobbyverbands DEHOGA natürlich will man
sich da beliebt machen ist ja logisch
für alles andere müssen wir ja schon
extrem blöd sein oder halt bei den
Grünen ne hier ja auch beim DEHOGA ein
grüner die 7% sind eine wichtige
Überbrückung gewesen ich glaube nicht
dass es auf Dauer fortgeführt WD kan der
Staat hat diese steuerein
[Applaus]
nicht mein Gott grüner jetzt lügt die
WTE einfach an es ist doch nicht so
schwer grüne ey zur Wahrheit gehört
fehlende Steuereinnahmen hin oder her
bei noch mehr Pleiten in der Branche
verliert der Staat ja auch die
Gastrobranche ist doppelt gekniffen
kosten plus fehlende Arbeitskräfte ja
ist ja so während der coronajahre haben
sich viele Köche und Kellner was anderes
gesucht und festgestellt so toll war es
gar nicht im Restaurant also was
verschlafen worden ist das ist zum einen
ja Personal menenschenführung in den
Betrieben wenn jemand köch oder Koch
lernt dann will er halt kochen und nicht
nur Tüten aufreißen und nicht
angeschrienen werden wussten sie
das die Leute werden gar nicht gerne
angeschrienen verwöhntes Pack du ja der
DEHOGA schätzt dass der Gastronomie
aktuell 65 000 Mitarbeiter fehlen
Wahnsinn in München loogt eine
Hotelkette in München logt eine
Hotelkette neue Azubis z.B mit gratis
Tattoos im Wert von 500 € ja ja
wahrscheinlich linker Arm
Speisekarte rechter Arm Weinkarte
Tageskarte
arschgewei so und andere Arbeitgeber
setzen gar nicht mehr auf Menschen er
braucht kein Urlaub er braucht nur ein
bisschen Strom er braucht keine Pausen
er kann 8 Stunden hintereinander fahren
dann muss man ihn erst aufladen er kann
haben bis zu 40 kg tragen also ist schon
großer Vorteil und die AFD so verdammte
Roboter nehmen unseren Ausländern die
Jobs
weg Kneipen und Restaurants sind als
soziale Treffpunkte wichtig für den
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt ist Fakt
und ohne sie wärden unsere verödeten
Innenstädte bald noch viel öder außerdem
geht's ja auch um Gerechtigkeitsfragen
ja es geht um Gleichbehandlung für
Lieferdienste gelt nämlich ab Januar
weiter die 7% Mehrwertsteuer ja
ausgerechnet für Lieferdienste die ohne
Ende Müll produzieren und unsere
Teenager immer dicker machen das sagt
der richtige ja gut meine na ich gehe
wenigstens noch in Restaurants meine
Damen und Herren aber viele jüngere
kennen ja seit Corona nur noch Essen vom
Lieferdienst wie erkläre ich den das E
liebes Lieferando Opfer lieber
übergewichtiger uberit in deiner mit
Pizzakartons zugemöten miebude steh doch
einfach mal auf und geh vor die Tür
experten nennen es
draußen ist im Grunde ja wie so eine 3D
Animation aber mit einer voll
realistischen Grafik und da in diesem
draußen findest du auch sogenannte
Restaurants und da Hulst du dann weil du
zum ersten Mal richtige Pizza istst also
nicht kalt und labrig wie vom
Bringdienst und da gibt's auch eine
Achtung anschnallen saubere Toilette
kennt er gar nicht kennt er auch nicht
immerhin die Inflation in Deutschland
sinkt so langsam zuletzt auf
4,5% das ist allerdings sagen Experten
auch ein statistisch Effekt weil vor
genau einem Jahr das 9 € Ticket
ausgelaufen ist und ausgerechnet bei den
Lebensmitteln waren es im September eben
doch wieder
7,5% herausfordernde Zeiten also für
Gastronomen wie Holga Stockhaus Holga
Stockhaus ist Inhaber von Holgis
schnitzelparadies der aktuelle
Fachkräftemangel macht ihm schwer zu
schaffen für wie viele Personen ist das
für zwei und wann Silvester in 3 Jahren
ja schreibe ich mir auf
hallo
[Musik]
Sekunde stimmt so danke und ein
Bewirtungsbeleg
g ist so schlimm alles muss man selber
machen keine Sau mehr Kellnern also ich
habe jetzt endlich einen gefunden aber
der stellt knallharte Bedingungen z.B
muss ich ihm jeden Tag eine
Fußreflexzonenmassage verpassen und er
darf jederzeit bei den Gästen mit essen
sonst kündigt er plus diese bescheuerten
mehrwertsteuerregeln die keine Sau
versteht Bratwurst vom Schwein 7% aber
sojawurst 19 ich meine klar jeder hasst
Vegetarier aber das geht ja n wirklich
zu weit oder hier Kaffee schwarz oder
mit einem kleinen Schuss Milch 19% mit
viel Milch 7 kein Witz ich meine wer
entscheidet was vielmch ist ja das
kontrolliert jemand vom
Finanzamt
die spinnen doch aber jetzt schlage ich
sie mit ihren eigenen Waffen Getränke
sind 19% Essen 7 so wenn ich jetzt aber
eine Fanta mit Gelatine
andicke dann ist sie kein Getränk mehr
sondern ein Dessert zack
7%. das hier serviere ich jetzt als
Riesling muss der Gast nur zwei Jahre
warten Olga Stockhaus ist lflich am
Ende ja das kann sein aber ich ma weiter
und ich were mich erhöht ihr ruhig eure
Mehrwertsteuer nächstes Jahr ich bin
vorbereitet ich bin jetzt nämlich auch
ein Lieferdienst einverstanden wer hatte
denn das
schnit nur
[Musik]
7% hallo leute wenn ihr jetzt auf
Gefällt mir drückt und den Kanal
abonniert zeige ich euch meinen
lautesten Schrei für das menschliche
Gehör ist der zwar nicht wahrzunehmen
aber ich würde eure Hunde kurz
rausbringen okay
fertig